as president Trump gets rid of President
Obama's executive amnesty sort of we'll
discuss all the ramifications North
Korea drops a hydrogen bomb and we'll
talk about what that means plus
president Trump visits Louisiana and
Texas and the media lose their minds of
course I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show all righty so I'm going to
explain everything you need to know
about president Trump's big move this
morning to curb the deferred action for
childhood arrivals program this is
President Obama's executive amnesty and
president Trump moves to sort of get rid
of it but it's sort of not and we'll
explain why this plan really doesn't
please anyone there's a better way to do
it there are a couple better ways to do
it
especially if you would like to see
immigration law enforced as I would like
to see immigration law enforced my
long-standing policy on illegal
immigration has always been that the
federal government should be working to
remove people not only criminals but
people who are not of benefit to
American society while leaving the
people who are a benefit for American
society to the back of the line this has
always been my policy on immigration
I've never seen why a blanket policy
with regards to entire classes of people
should be adopted it's never occurred to
me why it should be that everyone of a
particular age from a particular country
should get in or nothing should be that
doesn't make any sense to me but I'm
gonna explain why it is that what
President Trump did today is not likely
to please anyone on any side of the
aisle or to finish President Obama's
executive amnesty before I get to any of
that and I think Trump is trying but
before I get to any of that I first want
to say thanks to our sponsors over at
ring so right now there is a serious
problem with home burglaries if people
what people tend to do is they will ring
your doorbell see if your home if you're
not home then they will rob your house
well the ring video doorbell makes that
a thing of the past because when they
ring the doorbell the first thing that
happens is that you are notified on your
phone that there is someone at your door
you can answer your door you can explain
to people where exactly everything you
know that you are home that they're not
allowed to come in you can call the
police for using a even call the police
and do all these things to protect your
home and you can have them on video so
you know exactly who it is who's ringing
your doorbell anywhere in the world I
picked up the doorbell at my house in LA
when I'm on the East Coast so this thing
works all over the country also they
have something amazing
called the ring floodlight cam it's like
rings amazing doorbell but the
floodlight chemins a motion-activated
camera and floodlight that connects to
your phone with HD video on two-way
audio that lets you know the moment
anyone steps on your property you can
see and speak to visitors even set off
an alarm right from your phone so that
people are notified the cops are on
their way and they take off with the
floodlight cam when things go bump in
the night you will immediately know what
it is I am a stickler when it comes to
security because I've had so many death
threats on over the past couple of years
particularly and that means that I
really rely on my ring technology you
should too
right now you save up to one hundred and
fifty bucks off a ring of security kit
when you go to ring.com slash Ben that's
ring.com slash Ben again one hundred and
fifty dollars off that ring of security
kit which is something you ought to have
for your property make sure your entire
property is safe from intruders ring.com
slash Ben again it's a motion-activated
camera what the floodlight notifies you
all of it ring comm slash bending at
fifth and fifty dollars off that ring of
security kit and let them know that we
sent you by using that slash pen at the
end of the web address ring.com slash
gun okay so it was rumored over the
weekend for the past several days the
president Trump was going to announce an
end to President Obama's executive
amnesty so let's start from the very
beginning a very good place to start and
that is what exactly was the executive
amnesty in the first place so if you go
back to 2012 President Obama desperately
wanted to win the election and so what
he decided to do was give a stop to the
Hispanic community as he viewed it by
basically granting blanket amnesty to
so-called dreamers these would be
children of illegal immigrants who
arrived as children they weren't born in
the United States if they've been born
here they would be citizens but they
were brought to the United States
afterward and they were like three or
four years old or ten years old when
they came here the restrictions were
people who were under the age of 16 when
they were brought to the United States
and below the age of 31 brought into the
country by their parents before 2012
granted new legal status presumably he
had to be brought into the country I
guess by day I guess you wouldn't get a
permit unless you'd been in the country
since 2007 for some continuous period
and that was the basic rule under the
under the so called deferred action for
childhood arrivals program and there was
DAPA which was a program for their
parents the deferred action for parents
childhood arrivals okay so all of that
was put in place by Obama through an
executive order it never passed through
Congress it was not a piece of
legislation all it really was was Obama
giving paperwork to people saying that
they could work legally in the country
and him calling it a refusal to to
prosecute the law he said that he was
doing this under prosecutorial
discretion his DOJ was not gonna
prosecute any of these people and
therefore he might as well give them
papers this was challenged in court and
it was basically struck down because the
idea was it's one thing for you to say
you're not gonna prosecute folks it's
another thing for you to give them
papers if you give them papers it's no
longer a question of executive branch
power now we're talking about something
different we're talking about an
affirmative action by the executive
branch without legislative approval
that's illegal so doc I had basically
been held up by the courts but none of
the people who had applied through the
daca program were being deported and one
of the things that happened because of
all of this is a lot of people who are
illegal immigrants went to the
government registered all their
information because they were guaranteed
a shot at essentially amnesty if they
gave the information the problem was
always that if there was a situation
where the next president was a
Republican and decided to walk this back
now the government knew exactly where to
find you if you were an illegal
immigrant okay so here is what Trump did
he had a bunch of choices to what he
could do on Jacka
I'll explain what I think was the best
choice in just a few minutes but here's
what he actually did he announced that
the administration would stop
considerating a consideration of new
applications for legal status beginning
tomorrow so if you were going to apply
under daca for legal status and work
permit then that you can no longer do
that starting tomorrow
those whose current permits expire
between now and March 5th 2018 which is
next March can apply for a new two-year
permit they must do so before October
5th so they have to come along reapply
in the next month or so some so-called
dreamers will be granted new legal
status others will not but even after
March 5th which is the deadline for
enforcement of these daca
well that's the deadline where Trump
says it gets the drop-dead date now
we're gonna start enforcing the law he
really says we're not gonna start
enforcing law he says we're not going to
hand out new work permits or anything
but the Trump White House says it will
not start deporting dreamers in serious
numbers but will continue to follow the
Obama administration's focus on
criminals so basically nothing changed
except for we're not gonna get paperwork
to people and there's a little bit more
uncertainty if you're a dreamer maybe
Obama maybe Trump will deport you maybe
he won't
in all likelihood he will not okay a lot
of this Springs from a key ambiguity and
how the right wing feels about illegal
immigration and dreamers in particular
and this is a key ambiguity Trump
campaign loudly and proudly on the idea
that we have to have rule of law and
these people have to go it doesn't
matter if you were brought here as a
child
it's sad but we as a country have a
responsibility to fulfill the needs of
our citizens before we start fulfilling
the needs of other citizens you
shouldn't come here illegally your
parents shouldn't dub and we don't have
an obligation as a country to take in
anyone right that's not our
responsibility
that was what from said repeatedly
during the campaign at the same time
Trump was saying during the campaign
particularly afterward that he wants to
keep the dreamers here so he had the
Senate sort of split message here was
Trump just a few weeks ago talking about
how he loves the dreamers okay we love
the dreamers we love everybody she's got
these conflicting messages one is I want
to enforce the law too as we love the
dreamers so here is the split in the
Republican Party over Obama's executive
amnesty there is one every one sort of
wants the executive amnesty gone but for
two different reasons reason number one
it's illegal for the executive branch to
usurp legislative authority this way
this is the position of Speaker Paul
Ryan this is the position of a lot of
the sort of leftists in the Republican
Party on illegal immigration a lot of
them say you know we sort of like what
Obama did but we don't like that Obama
did it right Obama should have gone
through Congress we should have passed
legislation this is not something the
executive branch gets to do on its own
fair enough I agree it's
unconstitutional and the courts have
largely agreed with that as well the
second reason that people disliked
Obama's executive amnesty is because
they actually didn't like the executive
amnesty not because it was illegally
done not because it was done in in
piss-poor manner by the executive branch
but because they don't actually want
amnesty for dreamers this is Trump's
most vocal base this is people like Ann
Coulter this is people like Steve Ben
and this is people who were really on
the Trump train from the earliest point
right people like Jeff Sessions the
turning general these are people who
actually would like to see a lot of
dreamers deported and this is crystal
clear that there is the split in the
Republican Party
so Trump now has to make a choice is he
going to revoke daca on the first
grounds around the second grounds in
other words does she really agree with
his own base does you really want to get
rid of daca and start deporting dreamers
it's pretty clear that he does not it's
pretty clear to see that he does not and
it's pretty clear from his policy that
he doesn't because what it really looks
like he's doing right now is he is
saying that he's gonna get rid of daca
in order to push Congress in order to
actually enshrine daca and then maybe as
a stop to his base give him funding for
the Trump wall so this is the trade that
Trump is looking for Trump is looking
for this trade he wants daca to be
replaced okay not actually got rid of he
wants to see it encoded he wants to see
it enshrined he wants to see Congress
actually make Obama's executive amnesty
the law of the land not through the
executive branch he wants to sign into
law the executive amnesty so it's just a
mistake
my Trump actually wants that but in
return he also wants the Trump wall and
he's hoping that that will be enough of
a stop to his base this is a serious
problem this plan is not going to please
anyone the only people who might please
are some of the people who opposed daca
because of the manner in which was
implemented but they're lefties not
immigration people like Paul Ryan Paul
Ryan might be happy with this particular
plan and in fact Paul Ryan basically
came forward and said yeah I think we're
gonna try and pass something now but if
Trump's legacy in the first year of his
presidency is no Obamacare appeal no tax
cuts no getting rid of the Iran deal and
we will pass a piece of amnesty
legislation that is actually stronger
than what Obama did I think a lot of
people in his base are gonna be pissed
and they have good reason to be pissed
off so here's why everybody's gonna be
angry from all sides on this particular
policy for the people who are advocates
of getting rid of Jaca because of what
because they actually don't want to act
up because they want the dreamers
deported Trump clearly doesn't want to
deport the dreamers and the problem is
that Trump is already signals he doesn't
want to support the dreamers so imagine
you're a member of Congress and Trump is
coming to you and he's saying listen I'm
gonna get rid of Jaca I'm getting rid of
the executive amnesty and then I'm gonna
start deporting people but if you want
those people to stay all you have to do
oppa is give me the Trump ball that's
all you got to do just do it the Trump
wall imagine you're a Republican member
Congress now you are in serious trouble
because you are stuck between a rock and
a hard place if you vote to give Trump
what he wants your own base will crucify
you for having caved on daca your own
base will probably primary you for
having said that you're going to
enshrine daca and if you don't give
Trump what he wants then your own base
could go after you because you're not
giving trumple he wants so Trump has put
them all in an awkward position right
and this is a serious problem for the
for the people in the Republican Party
so what's their easiest solution their
easiest solution is to do nothing
because they know that in the end Trump
actually isn't going to implement his
new band Trump isn't actually gonna
deport all these people so all these
Republicans can just sit tight stay out
of the fight vote for nothing and then
six months pass and then Trump basically
does nothing and everything goes back to
normal and whatever right that's the
easiest solution no Trump wall no
nothing no legislation Republicans don't
want to have to affirmative Lyonne the
executive amnesty they don't want to
have to do that but Trump wants them to
do that so they'll give him the Trump
wall and also because then it's not on
him right then it's not Trump's
responsibility for not getting rid of
the executive amnesty it's all
Congress's responsibility for not
getting rid of the executive amnesty so
basically Trump is kicking the can down
the road because he doesn't want to take
responsibility for getting rid of the
executive amnesty in the first place
all right Trump wants to make a deal and
Trump's deal is not something his base
is going to be happy with and then there
are the people who love daca and they're
not gonna be happy either and I'll
explain why in just a second but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at the u.s. concealed-carry
Association so it's the middle of the
night your wake up because you hear
somebody at the door
bashing at the door with a crowbar
breaking the window try and get into
your house you grab your gun you go to
the kitchen and there's some dude in
your kitchen and you shoot him that's
the end of the story right well no
actually that's just the beginning of
the story the cops are gonna show up
they're gonna ask all sorts of questions
they may arrest you because they don't
have all the information you may end up
stuck inside the legal system that's why
you need to talk to my friends or if you
just concealed-carry association if you
go to defend my family now.com right now
defend my family now calm it'll give you
all the information you need about what
you should and you should not say to the
police that's the single most important
thing that you can discover today it
could mean the difference between
freedom and a jail cell even if you do
the right thing go to defend my family
now calm right now to claim your copy of
the US you see is free
guide that will uncover the six things
you didn't know what happened when the
police arrived early this is vital
reading for any law-abiding citizen of
the United States who wants to have the
option of using your second Amendment
rights when someone steps on your
property in the dead of night defend my
family now calm gives you this free
guide to tell you what you should and
should not say when the police arrive on
your premises again that's defend my
family now calm defend my family now
calm they also sell you insurance you
get insurance from them to insure you
against legal fees against bail funds if
indeed you have to use your second
Amendment rights great service u.s. CCA
these are people who will give you the
education you need plus they'll give you
the insurance you need in case something
bad happens and you have to actually
fire your gun in self-defense defend my
family now calm again that's defend my
family now calm okay so I've already
discussed the people who want to get rid
of Jack like really want to get rid of
it they're gonna be upset because Trump
doesn't actually want to get rid of daca
he just wants to make Congress rien
shrined daca and then give him the trump
wall as some sort of stop people like
Ann Coulter are not gonna be happy with
this and they shouldn't be happy with
this if they are they're being
disingenuous because Trump is basically
saying that he's not going to deport
dreamers okay that was not what he ran
on okay then there are a bunch of people
who love daca right these are people
like John McCain they're not gonna be
happy because they're gonna suggest okay
well if you're just going to reinstall
dak on the first place why not just
leave Obama's policies in place why are
we going through this whole rigmarole
why are we putting uncertainty in the
heads of all these dreamers who are
gonna get to stay in the first place why
are you destroying the credibility of
the party on this question you don't
know you're not gonna get rid of these
folks so what exactly is the political
move here that's what people like John
McCain are saying and on the left of
course the left is always gonna claim
that Trump is a racist sexist pig at
homophobe even if Trump didn't actually
change anything here and by the way
Trump didn't really change much here
okay dreamers are not being deported the
White House says that they are only
going after what they call criminals not
illegal immigrants criminal illegal
immigrants people have committed an
additional crime
besides being here illegally not what
Trump ran on okay so Trump is not
actually getting rid of daca this is
very much like the health care debate
it's very much like Trump care Trump was
basically saying I'm getting rid of
Obama care he wasn't getting rid of
Obama care and then no Republican wanted
to go on record as having reinsuring
Obama care and so Trump care failed this
is almost the exact same thing you can
see the exact same math playing out
again because
Trump won't take ownership of this Trump
was not willing to take a hard position
here he wasn't either willing to come
out and say full-scale listen I like the
dream I like daca jack is good so here's
the deal let's just pass daca he's not
willing to say that cuz he knows his
base we'll go after him and he's also
not willing to own his own hardline
immigration position the one that he
sold during the campaign that were gonna
deport everybody who's not here
illegally the who's not here legally
he's not actually willing to take that
stand so how exactly does all this play
out well it plays out with nothing
happened happening basically because
Republicans are split on Jack now the
chances that a piece of legislation
passes here a big piece of amnesty
legislation passes with solely
Republican support is low Democrats have
no incentive to actually pass anything
Democrats want to run on this there's a
lot of optimistic thinking from people
like my friend Hugh Hewitt the Democrats
may jump on board and pass a piece of
bipartisan legislation with Trump rien
shrining daca they're not going to
Democrats want to run on this in 2018
they love the Vice the Republicans are
now caught in Republicans are caught
between their base and the general
public the general public is basically
okay with the dreamers the base really
is not that means that all of these
Republicans are now going to be forced
to go on record with either a very
unpopular position with their base or a
very unpopular position with the general
public okay this is bad politics now the
reason it's particularly bad politics is
because there is a better solution
there's a far easier solution okay this
one was suggested by Byron New York of
the Washington Examiner it was a big
Trump fan okay Byron York suggests
there's a very simple solution here and
he is totally right that is instead of
Trump coming out and having Jeff
Sessions make a statement about getting
rid of Obama's executive amnesty instead
Trump simply could have used the same
strategy that Obama used on same-sex
marriage if you recall Obama's strategy
on same-sex marriage was not to come out
personally and endorse some sort of
executive action right that's not what
Obama actually did what Obama actually
did was something very different what he
did was he waited for a bunch of states
to sue and then he said we're not going
to defend traditional marriage we're not
gonna defend it in court
right I'm not gonna make Eric Holder
defend traditional marriage in court and
then the Supreme Court said oh well
there's nobody who's actually defending
traditional marriage so we'll strike
down a traditional marriage right this
is what
from this is what Obama did with
same-sex marriage Oh trunk could have
done exactly the same thing with the
executive amnesty like beat for beat
note-for-note he could have done the
exact same thing all Trump had to do was
just wait for all of these lawsuits
against daca to go forward wait for daca
to be struck down and then say listen
guys if you want daca back just pass a
piece of legislation that includes
funding for the Trump wall that would
have been a smartest move you could have
waited for daca to be struck down and
say nothing keep his mouth shut and then
he could have gone forward DAC would
have been dead and now it's up to
Congress to fix the problem instead
Trump has taken this weird position
where he struck down zack on procedural
grounds but not on substantive grounds
and his fans wanted to strike it down on
substantive grounds Trump would have all
the leverage once the courts got rid of
Obama's executive dynasty Trump would
have every bit of leverage all the
leverage not some of it all of it
because then we'd go back to the system
beforehand and Trump wouldn't have even
said anything yet right
Trump could have had a credible threat
listen there's no law in the books
preventing me from doing this
I don't have to get rid of executive
amnesty executive amnesty was illegal
and listen we have to enforce the law
that's what the law is on the books so
guys either fix it or go home fix it and
give me my wall right that's not what
Trump did here so this is actually
really bad strategy it's actually very
poor strategy particularly going into a
midterm and what it comes from is for
president Trump I think a deep and
abiding need not to be the bad guy I
mean this is actually one of the things
that's sort of fascinating my president
Trump is a person is that Trump does not
want to be the bad guy in any given
scenario he doesn't actually like firing
people for a guy who likes firing people
and it plays the bad guy on TV a lot he
doesn't actually like doing the dirty
work of punching someone he doesn't
actually like doing it when he got rid
of James Comey he tried to put it on his
deputy attorney general rod Rosenstein
when he got rid of Mike Flynn he tried
to make it look like Flynn was resigning
when he when he got rid of Stephen and
he tried to make it look like Bannon was
resigning like every move that Trump
makes is designed to shift
responsibility to someone else on this
one he's trying to shift responsibility
to Congress well he could have done that
without even getting his hands dirty but
what he's doing by doing this so
obviously is he's trying to posture for
his base saying listen I'd get rid of
daca but this Congress you know it's up
to them now I can't I don't know right
by shifting responsibility to Congress
he's avoiding the responsibility of
having
take a position and that's not good
because without that presidential
leadership daca will be enshrined okay
Congress will try to pass something and
you can see a situation very easily
where speaker Ryan Mitch McConnell they
actually decides to put forward bills
with Democrats support enshrining daca
or they decide to let this thing go all
the way for six months and then Trump
has the situation back on his hands you
can see Congress kick the ball right
back to trump and then Trump says well
you know and then we just go on the way
we were before if you're Trump space I
don't know that you can be happy with
this like if you're gonna be
intellectually honest I don't think that
you can be particularly happy with this
and again I'm the guy who wrote the
headline a week and a half ago when
Trump was talking about getting rid of
executive amnesty I'm the guy who a week
and a half ago said that that was a good
thing worth doing but it's only good and
worth doing if you're willing to enforce
the law or replace it with a better law
it's not worth doing if your entire goal
here is just to sort of posture about it
and then go right back to the same
enforcement policy that Obama had that's
not good and it's certainly not a good
policy if you want Congress to enshrine
executive amnesty is the law right it's
not it's not good on Trump it's not
going on Ryan it's not gonna Connell
it's really it's laid out about as
poorly as you can I wish I could I wish
I could say the Trump was doing a
beautiful job with this but I just don't
think he is I think that he's unwilling
to face up to the conflicts inside the
Republican Party and take a hard
position so he split the baby splitting
the baby in politics is basically the
worst possible strategy I don't want to
explain about that in a second why
Republicans have a tendency to split the
baby while Democrats really don't I'm
gonna explain that in just one second
but first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at blankets so you're an
information junkie you are if you're
listening to this show it's because you
love having information mainlined into
your brain it's just something that
you're into all the time well over at
blink cast they ensure that you are
going to be able to read five books a
day how do you read five books a day
well what they do is in these are not
audio books they are basically point the
major points of a book they sum up the
major points of some of the best-selling
books in America and they give them to
you in these 15-minute packages they
call blinks so if you're on the road for
a half an hour and you're stuck in
traffic and city you're just wasting
that time you can now get through two
best-selling books two of these books
that you've always wanted to read but I
don't have time to get through 700 pages
it'll cost you you know three days to
get through that book instead of doing
that
you can listen in 15 minutes get the
main points of the book the fact is
after we read a book folks you're not
going to remember 600 of the 700 pages
you might remember four or five of the
key points in any given book that you
read you get those key points from
Linkous without actually having to read
the book and it really is terrific they
have over 2000 of the best-selling
non-fiction books transformed into these
powerful packs you can read or listen to
in just 15 minutes and you can learn on
the go blink astiz awesome and right now
they have a special offer just for our
audience if you go to blink accom slash
bend right now you can start your free
trial or you get three months off your
yearly plan when you join today
that's blink as to be li NK ist blink is
calm slash been to start your free trial
or get three months off your yearly plan
again that's blink is calm slash Ben and
some of the titles here are just that
I've read a lot of these books and I
promise you I don't remember 15 minutes
worth of material from the books I
enjoyed the books but you can enjoy what
the books have to say without spending
the hours of actually having to do it
the power of habit great book flow drive
these are all books about how to make
yourself more efficient Thinking Fast
and Slow which is a terrific book by
Daniel Kahneman about all about human
behaviour like a 500 page book you can
read that book in in 15 minutes I mean
you don't have to read it you just get
the main points of the book and it tells
you what you need to know again blink
astiz terrific it is smart it is
informal but not sloppy it is it is just
it's great it gives you everything that
you need to know in any of these books
bar none it's the bet it's one of those
services that you can get on your on
your phone blink is calm / pens start
that free trial get three months off
your yearly plan really is a great
service okay so here is the problem for
Republicans what Obama did he did a lot
of it while he was presidents of the
United States he shifted the ground he
shifted the ground that's what Obama did
that's what Obamacare was this is what
Democrats understand that Republicans
don't Democrats understand that when you
have power you have to use it now and
even if it means that you're gonna lose
it for a little while you change the
nature of the playing field so when's
the last time Republicans had unilateral
control of Congress and the presidency
and they passed a major piece of
legislation that shifted the groundwork
making it nearly impossible for
Democrats to roll back when's the last
time Republicans had control of all
three branches of government from 2002
to 2006 nothing major passed nothing
didn't shift the Graham
in any substantial way Democrats had
control of the house the Senate in the
presidency from 2008 to 2010 or 2009 to
2011 and in that time they passed
Obamacare which dramatically shifted the
groundwork now Democrats lost a thousand
seats across the country they lost the
house Senate and presidency on the back
of Obamacare they didn't care the reason
they didn't care is because they now
understand that they've shifted the way
Americans think about health care we now
think it is government's job to provide
you health care once were in that world
Democrats have now won they've now taken
another area of territory off the board
and they just took Casterly Rock they
may have lost a lot of troops to do it
they may have they may have put
themselves in a bad political positions
now bad political position is temporary
the change they made is permanent
Democrats understand this same thing is
true of executive amnesty by Obama
moving forward on executive amnesty
he lost Congress in 2014 based on his
executive amnesty there's a huge
backlash to the executive amnesty but
because he knew that was gonna shift the
groundwork that was gonna make people
feel like there were eight hundred
thousand people who basically been given
legal amnesty in the United States
he knew that walking that back was going
to be damaging for Republicans he
shifted the groundwork Republicans are
never willing to make those same sorts
of sacrifices Republicans could have
gone for broke on Obamacare on repealing
it they could have changed the
circumstances on a fundamental level
they didn't hey they could do it on
taxes they're not going to they could do
it right now on amnesty they're not
going to instead Republicans are always
fearful of losing power because when
you're a conservative your typical job
is to stop Democrats from doing insane
things but the problem is that if you
think your only job is to stop Democrats
from doing insane things you can only do
that so long as you have power well
you're never gonna have power
indefinitely that means that if
Democrats have power for five minutes
boom they shift the game the playing
fields has now been tilted and now
you're fighting an even more uphill
battle and so you say okay well the
playing fields already uphill we can't
lose power we can't afford to lose power
they'll shift the playing field some
more so they don't do anything they
don't try to shift it back to level they
don't try to shift the playing field
back to level instead they stand right
here and they say okay we'll fight the
uphill battle we'll try to stop that
snowball from rolling down the hill then
they don't do anything they lose power
and Democrats boom they move the entire
hill right the hill again shifts
okay so this is why Republicans are
failing at this imagine of President
Trump would come out and yet said listen
we are now going to enforce immigration
law the rule of law is back in force
it's back in force and the new
immigration law that we are going to
enforce is that if you are not here and
ace and of benefits of the United States
you're gone that'd be a very difficult
policy for Democrats to fight because
most people in the United States believe
that on a fundamental level but Trump
isn't willing to do that because he's
not he's afraid of the bad headlines and
he doesn't want to be a bad guy and the
same thing is true of Republicans in
Congress basically Republicans are a
bunch of cowards on this issue just like
they are cowards on a number of issues
and they are not willing to take a
hard-and-fast political position because
they're afraid of the blowback if they
do which will give Democrats back power
and then Democrats will move faster what
they fail to see is that if you do not
expend political capital you can never
shift the playing field back in your
direction in any serious way so this is
a it's it's a serious problem and and
I'm not sure that Republicans know how
to fix it I want to talk about North
Korea as well because over the weekend
this this deccan is the executive
amnesty news has obviously shifted the
political discussion but the actual
biggest news over the weekend was that
North Korea tested out a hydrogen bomb
which is pretty shocking we'll talk
about that but for that you're gonna
have to go over to Daley we're not calm
and to come up become a subscriber for
$9.99 a month you can become a
subscriber to daily wire.com get the
rest of this show live you can also get
Enric Levens show live they'll be
starting in just about 45 minutes here
and get Michael Knowles's show live you
get all those shows live later when we
post them on our daily wire web site
then you can watch them without any ads
you also get our website ad free even
part of the mailbag on all three of
those shows we do our mailbag here on
Fridays and get your questions answered
I get hundreds of emails a day from
people who want that questions answered
I can't answer all your questions but if
you're a subscriber your question will
be answered in our mailbag segment which
we do every Friday you get all that for
$9.99 a month if you become an annual
subscriber for ninety nine dollars a
year you not only get those things you
also get this the greatest of all
possible beverage vessels the leftist
years hot or cold mug it cannot be
duplicated it cannot be competed with
there are others who have mugs on the
market this is incomparable it is much
nicer it is something you will treasure
every day of your life plus I'm like
those other mugs it's actually a tumbler
so you can bring it in the car and close
it and snot gonna spill all over you
it's pretty awesome so leftist here's
hot or cold mug
you get that as well or you just want to
listen later on iTunes or SoundCloud
please go over to iTunes subscribe leave
us a review it's great for us when you
leave a serve you it always helps us
with the rankings and the news and
politics which means that iTunes has to
listen on their front page which helps
us and lets people know that we're out
there make sure you do all of that we
are the largest and fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so what's odd about what Obama's doing
with the what Trump rather is doing with
the executive amnesty is that Trump
actually has some serious political
capital now in the aftermath of the
hurricane Trump has real political
capital here's some video of President
Trump in Louisiana over the weekend and
here he is he decide to make a second
trip down to the storm torn region and
hand out supplies and do some photo ops
which is stuff that is good for him
obviously I here's some video of Trump
in Louisiana you can see this enormous
crowd that showed up for Trump
and here he is in one of the trucks
shaking hands with people with the happy
nappy music Trump shaking hands with
some more folks and and then here is
some video of Trump at the Houston
listed Houston shelter tapes of here he
is at the Houston shelter talking to a
bunch of the victims of hurricane Harvey
talking about how bad all this was it's
been really nice if there it's been a
wonderful thing it's as truck as tough
as this was it's been a wonderful thing
I think even for the country to watch it
for the world to watch have a good time
everybody I'm going to be doing a little
help over here okay
they're really happy with what's going
on it's been something I've been very
well received even maybe you guys just
been
now I didn't see you mean the flooding
oh yeah yeah that was there's a lot of
water but it's it's leaving pretty quick
and pretty quickly but there's a lot of
water a lot of water but it's moving out
but I think most importantly the
governor the relationship with the
governor and the mayor and everybody
it's been fantastic and with and with
the federal government has been
we're signing a lot of documents now to
get money so all of this is fine right
all this tape for Trump is very good and
you can see that the left are losing
their mind because anytime Trump does
something that's good for Trump the left
think that this is the end of the world
so joy read over on MSNBC she was very
angry because Trump says he's gonna give
a million dollars to hurricane Harvey
relief and here she is whining that it's
not enough money
his million-dollar pledge is also
dwarfed by the efforts of celebrities
like Beyonce and JJ Watt who have
launched their own fundraising campaigns
with wot raising 16 million dollars and
Counting okay so you know there she is
ripping him and then Gabe Sherman from
New York magazine he comes out and says
the big problem here is that Trump is
really trying just to avoid
responsibility for the Muller
investigation that as the Muller Russian
investigation goes on he doesn't want to
focus on that so he's going over to
hurricane Harvey land this is just again
this shows how crazy the left is when
the left is this crazy folks that's an
indication that Trump is winning that's
always a good indicator when the left
goes nuts it's for one of two reasons
one Trump actually did something
completely illegitimate or - it's not
that illegitimate and they're just going
crazy because he's winning that's this
right Trump did something that's not
illegitimate it's actually quite good
you went down to Louisiana and Texas and
did some photo opping and the left is
trying to suggest why this is bad and
having a tough time of it well this is a
desperate effort by this White House to
come up with a new storyline because the
story that Donald Trump doesn't want the
world focused on is the robert muller
investigation which we know from new
reporting this week that is moving ahead
at rapid-fire speed he's teamed up with
New York State Attorney General Eric
Schneiderman I mean this is a perilous
time for this president
so having any kind of visual or optics
where he's in Texas is his effort to
turn that corner okay so you know this
idea that the left is is going after
Trump for stuff that is completely
unobjectionable it demonstrates that
Trump had political capital now you
would assume that Trump might use that
political capital to do something big or
politically popular and instead he
decided to do the sort of milquetoast
move on the executive amnesty which is
actually designed to again reinsuring
the executive amnesty to make the
executive amnesty law that's what
Trump's move is explicitly designed to
do he's saying it it's not me saying it
people in the White House are saying it
all right that seems to me a really
foolish move he has all this political
cap
we'll use it mr. president use it for
something good you said last week you
wanted to do the tax cuts use it for the
tax cuts if that's how you want to use
this you want to say that we need to jog
the economy after a big disaster now be
a good time to do that listen I don't
agree with his trillion-dollar
infrastructure plans but if Trump wanted
to do that would there be a better time
than right after a hurricane all right
could he could even tie it to the
hurricane Harvey relief funds instead it
looks like Trump is is making minor
moves because I really don't get the
feeling that he has strong convictions
on a lot of these policies
you know Steve minuchin was suggesting
that that Congress should tie the
hurricane Harvey relief fund to a debt
ceiling increase I mean again this
president came into office complaining
that the government spent too much money
and now they're gonna go out they're
gonna borrow some more money
here's Steve minuchin is his secretary
of the Treasury Park medel's says he
does not want to see that disaster aid
tied to a bill to raise the debt limit
can you guarantee him and others that
that won't happen no no I can't quite
quite the contrary the president and I
believe that it should be tied to the
Harvey funding that our first priority
is to make sure that the state gets
money it is critical and to do that we
need to make sure we raise the debt
limit so if we if Congress appropriates
the money but I don't have the ability
to borrow more money and pay for it
we're not going to be able to get that
money to the state so we need to put
politics aside and we're going to be
urging Congress to get both of those
things done as quickly as they can so
this is what's driving me crazy you know
there's a whole very partisan feel to
the United States right now never have
the parties been closer in actual policy
Obama would have pushed the same thing
tie hurricane funding to a debt ceiling
increase that's exactly what Obama would
have pushed Obama would have pushed
making his executive amnesty law not
just executive amnesty these are all
things Obama would have pushed and yet
we're beating each other's brains in
over everyone agreeing on policy it's
quite insane okay meanwhile on the
international scene the the North
Koreans launched a they did a nuclear
test that actually created a six point
three earthquake that's how large this
hydrogen bomb was so they now have an
h-bomb and they are suggesting that they
can fix it to the tip of these ICBMs
that they've been test firing and that
are capable of reaching the United
States
President Trump had a series of tweets
on this over the weekend Rosie Tweety
tweeted North Korea has conducted a
major nuclear test their words and
actions continue to be very hostile and
dangerous to the United States he
continued North Korea is a rogue nation
which has become a great threat in
embarrassment to China which is trying
to help but with little success and then
you finish by saying South Korea is
finding his I have to told them that
their talk of appeasement in North Korea
will not work they only understand one
thing again the I don't want criticize
Trump too much because I don't think
that this was it's not a problems making
it's a problem of Clinton's making it's
a problem of every president since
Truman's making is is North Korea but
when he says things like South Korea is
finding that their appeasement doesn't
work only one thing works what's the one
thing force threats of force how's that
gonna work exactly how's that gonna work
so Trump was suggesting over the weekend
that he's going to actually lead
sanctions on any country that does
business with North Korea the problem is
that I'm not sure that he's actually
willing to implement that cuz it would
cause a pretty significant financial
strain it may actually be smart policy
it may actually be best policy Mark
Levin was suggesting on his show the
best thing the United States could do
would be to station nuclear weapons in
Japan pointed at North Korea in South
Korea pointed at North Korea basically
use the the anti-soviet strategy in
order to get North Korea to calm down
like let them know that if you were to
nuke any of these places they'd have the
immediate they have the immediate
backlash capacity that it's not a
question of whether they would nuke they
would I think that's right he also
suggested that we take financial
measures against China I think that's
right as well but when Trump is going
after South Korea I don't really see
that as being particularly a smart move
also Trump is threatening to end a trade
agreement with the South Koreans in the
middle of a conflict with the North
Koreans I don't understand how alienated
the South Korean government is a really
smart strategy at this point Trump is
talking about withdrawing from a trade
deal again one of the reasons South
Korea is working with us and not China
is because we have a trade relationship
with them if we don't then presumably
South Korea could start working with
China and China's sphere of influence
could grow under the North Korean
nuclear umbrella none of that makes a
whole hell of a lot of sense so again I
think the president from he says this is
a big week I agree this is a big week so
far I'm not liking what I'm seeing he
needs to take a straw
understand see the Salette on an actual
policy not just vague talk on Twitter an
actual policy on North Korea if he has
one and when it comes to executive
amnesty does he believe what he said
during the campaign or was he fibbing
does he want Congress to make sure the
dreamers aren't deported and if so then
he ought to take the leading position on
that and protect his own people from
being primary otherwise he's doing his
own party which seems to me like a bad
move okay time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things I like I was reading this book
over the weekend after my father
recommended it to me it's quite good
it's called the Black Swan by Nassim
Nicholas Taleb or Talib it's it's all
about why we spend all of our lives
trying to discern the system's behind
predictable events but the events that
actually change our lives in major ways
are highly improbable and unpredictable
events and that's why we have to plan
for those as well so how do you plan for
the unpredictable well one of the ways
is you have a certain amount of your
assets for example in the financial
market you have a certain amount of your
assets in really really predictable safe
assets and then you take a certain
percentage and you put them in high risk
things because one of those risks could
come up green and all of a sudden you're
making a billion dollars that's sort of
his investment strategy when it comes to
planning for foreign policy the same
thing you should try and think of every
possible contingency because the fact is
that there gonna be some things that
happen that you don't know about like I
think for example that the risk of North
Korea nuking us is actually much lower
than the risk of Pakistan initiating a
nuclear war at this point because I
think North Korea knows that they don't
want to be destroyed right now there's a
better chance that the Pakistani
government files - falls to the Taliban
for example and suddenly you have the
Taliban in charge of nuclear weapons and
they don't care all right same thing
with Iran so you know the Black Swan is
a really interesting way of looking at
the world that most people don't think
about talks about sort of what happens
if all of life is is if all of life's
events are identifiable on a bell curve
and most of those events happen in the
center of the bell curve the Black Swan
is about why the events that happen all
the way out here on the ends of the bell
curve those are the ones that really
determine the fate of countries and the
fate of individual lives okay other
things that I like so I have to I have
to laugh I thought this was funny what
Trump did so Hillary Clinton her new
book is called what happened and so
Trump tweeted out or retweeted a meme
that was going around as
is what happened Hillary Rodham Clinton
and then the response is I happen and
it's just a picture of Trump so I do
think that that's funny you know it's
it's typical Trump it's people who love
this love this about from people who
hate this hate this about Trump but
there's some truth to it obviously and
Trump did fight Hillary in a way that a
lot of other candidates would not have
so when when people say oh well if Trump
hadn't won then Rubio would have won I'm
not sure that that's the case I'm not
sure that campaign runs even close to
the same way okay time for a quick
couple of quick things I hate so thing I
hate number one Jesse Jackson literally
he came out over the weekend and said
President Trump is definitely not gonna
make it into the kingdom of heaven Trump
says you must be able to speak the
language English qualified and have a
job skill Jesus would not qualify the
come in Trump's country he would not
qualify the get in Jesus's Kingdom okay
so why is it that Jesse Jackson gets to
be the spokesperson for God's kingdom
now calm down there Augustine this this
routine where a guy who is known to have
had affairs as a reverend who's been
involved in alleged criminal activity
for many years you know that this is
yeah him being the great judge of who
goes into heaven to not it seems to me a
little bit of a stretch I have my
criticism to the Trump on a personal
level but whether it goes to heaven or
not seems to me much more of a God
decision than a Jesse Jackson decision
okay final thing that I hate there's
this tape that's going around and these
are going around now all the time on the
Internet these parents who are looking
for attention and a media willing to
grant it to them they've decided to
destroy the lives of their children
these parents took an eight-year-old boy
and made him into a drag queen and then
all of the media decided to trumpet this
as just the bravery of the parents the
kids ate okay the kid doesn't have
hormones yet it's not like you're
talking about a 15 year old boy okay
you're talking about an eight year old
who's not even hit puberty yet and
you're destroying his life because guess
what his school's gonna be like next
year guess what it's gonna be like when
all the kids at school say well what
like is he actually a girl no he's just
a boy who likes dressing as a girl
this kid could grow out of this stage I
mean why would you like I think that
it's actually nasty for parents to post
stuff of their kids on the Internet
and pretty much any point because kids
deserve privacy they're still figuring
out who they
and here you are making your kid into a
mockery in order for you to feel good
about yourself as though you're some
sort of tolerant parent because you're
eight-year-olds one do something that's
what my kids want to do stupid crap all
the time you're right I tell them no cuz
I'm in the parent it's my job to guard
them from their own stupidity it's my
job to guard them listen if you decide
as a parent that you want your kids do
this do it in the privacy of your own
home but exposing this to public view to
millions of viewers what's this kid's
life gonna be like you didn't give it
crap about your kid you really but the
media of course is happy to run with us
lactation is the devious diva you could
ever think of transforms into a young
Queen named - - sounds like threes and
fours even like twos and I've been
dancing around in like little pink
dresses and stuff so yeah I think I've
had lactation inside of me since I was
born and that's why I love that song
along this way we just want our kids to
express themselves really shot you're
funny this respect Jessica people mom I
like dancing and I like performing and I
love you like I love dressing up it
makes me feel very happy like I am
accepted with the red dress and then the
blonde wave with this dress when he was
about two he came to me with mr. Potato
Head earrings and asked me to put makeup
on him so we did a little like drag
photo shoot and he duck face it was very
sweet and yeah anytime he wanted makeup
I just put some on a little bit of dark
news news - and then a little bit of
power couple I want okay I have a
question where's dad you see dad
anywhere in here I'm not seeing dad
anywhere in here you know wax I don't
think dad's here I think this is I think
this is a mom who is very screwed up
screwing up her kid from the time the
kid is 2 because she wants attention and
how do I know she wants attention
because now I'm gonna say something that
is stereotypical but true okay if you
wear giant if you wear giant nose rings
and you have tattoos across your chest
and you wear low-cut things to
demonstrate the tattoos across your
chest I'm gonna go out on a limb here
you want attention okay just go out on a
limb here you're not somebody who is in
introvert taking an eight-year-old and
suggesting an eight-year-old is capable
of making decisions about the rest of
his life
before he's even had a sexual feeling is
just it's just devastating it's just
devastating and and she's been doing
this to the kids since the kid was to
well well done parents I mean the child
endangerment sure to pick this kid up
from his parents a long time ago really
just garbage parenting your job as a
parent is to guide your child not to
indulge a two-year-old fantasies what
stupidity and what horror the the moment
of society decides parents are not to be
parents but children are to be adults
and adults should act like children the
society is done okay so we will be back
tomorrow I'd like to see and what
President Trump has to say I'm sure
there will be more fallout from his
decision about executive amnesty and
we'll see whether the right wing is
willing to go along with him or whether
they are going to make a more honest
assessment of what this policy actually
is I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]